a teenager in russia has been sentenced
to prison for plotting to blow up a
government building the crazy part
though the building isn't real it only
exists in minecraft
[Music]
all right every now and again we get an
eyebrow raising story like this they
really do come out of the blue though so
the only way to make sure you don't miss
them is to subscribe to the score
esports that way you'll never miss a
video like this in the future the story
begins in the russian city of kansk in
the summer of 2020 nikita uvarov and two
other teenagers were detained for
handing out leaflets in support of a
mathematician called azat miftakov he
was a postgraduate student who was found
guilty in january 2021 of involvement in
an arson attack on a building owned by
united russia the country's ruling party
his case gained some global attention
when two and a half thousand
mathematicians wrote a letter urging the
international congress of mathematicians
to assist in his release despite the
guilty verdict azad's case was not
forgotten by the likes of nikita and his
friends age 14 at the time the leaflets
they were handing out included words of
support for him and also stated that the
main terrorist was the fsb russia's
primary security agency the fsb went
through the teenager's phones and found
videos of the group making pyrotechnics
and throwing molotov cocktails at a wall
according to the moscow times the mother
of one of the accused dennis mikhailenko
had said quote i always knew where he
was even when they were making these
bombs but it was a small childish prank
a child's bomb but that's not all they
found on the teenager's phones they also
found plans to blow up a local fsb
building in minecraft as a joke let me
just say that one more time they plan to
blow up a local government building in
minecraft as a joke but that is not how
the local authorities saw it nikita's
accomplices in all of this were cleared
of all charges and handed suspended
sentences for assisting authorities but
nikita himself wasn't so lucky the 16
year old is now serving five years in a
penal colony for this training for
terrorist activities a charge which
likely includes both the physical
explosive making and the minecraft
antics now for those of us in the west
this might seem a little bit extreme
sending a kid to prison for years for at
least in part plotting to blow things up
in a video game and even that's a good
point to know they didn't actually blow
up anything in minecraft this is all an
alleged plot to blow something up in
minecraft these kind of sentences have
become somewhat of a grim trend in
russia president putin has overseen a
new norm where young russians are
charged with preemptive terrorism
charges and given lengthy prison time in
august 2020 young activists of an
anarchist group called new greatness
were handed prison time for allegedly
plotting to overthrow the government
something which their supporters
maintain is fabrication earlier that
same year in february members of a group
known as set or in english network were
given sentences between 6 and 18 years
for alleged plots to overthrow the
government their lawyers have claimed
that guilty confessions only came after
they were tortured the point is being
young in russia doesn't really offer you
much protection when it comes to charges
of threatening the government alleged
physical or verbal threats have been met
with an iron fist in recent years but
this minecraft thing is something new
can planning to do things that take
place in a video game be used as
evidence to try someone for preemptive
terrorism at least in russia it seems we
now have an answer
[Music]
you